this video is sponsored by opera gx do
you use the internet that's a trick
question i know you do do you like
playing video games another trick
question gamers are always talking about
the newest graphics card or processor or
console to upgrade their arsenal but
what about upgrading your browser bet
you didn't think of that one if you're
not using opera gx for all of your
internet needs then frankly my dear
you're living in the middle ages
performance nerds like myself know all
too well that browsers like google
chrome can take up loads of cpu or ram
usage with only a few tabs open but with
opera gx you can access the gx control
panel with the click of a button to
monitor hot tabs and limit network ram
or cpu usage to ensure you never use
more gaming resources than you want but
just like no gaming rig is complete
without that sweet sweet rgb
customization opera gx allows you to
customize your browser like no other
browser has before you can choose from
dozens of special themes colors animated
wallpapers or upload your own
backgrounds and choose your own colors
want to watch a show or live stream
while working on something no problem
the video pop out feature allows you to
pop out videos in a separate adjustable
video frame that you can place anywhere
over anything and you can log into your
twitch or discord or twitter or whatever
you're on and keep up to date right in
the sidebar and if you're just in
eliciting mood that's no problem either
because you can log into apple music or
spotify or youtube music whatever you're
on and stream to your heart's content it
even plays and pauses automatically if
you start a video and if you're worried
about losing all your years of bookmarks
and cookies and whatever from your
current browser don't be because you can
just use the quick import tool to bring
everything over from whatever browser
you're using now easy peasy so gamer if
you're interested in upgrading your
browser click the link in the
description below to download opera gx
today completely for free and now on to
the video
dogs am i right there are so many
reasons to love dogs they're
good-natured loyal considered man's best
friend they're the only animal that can
actively try to kill you and you still
feel like deep down they're just a good
boy who needs a belly rub in a treat in
elden ring there are dogs some that look
like dogs and some that look like not
dogs unfortunately all of the ones that
look like actual dogs try to kill you
including one dog in particular that's
more of a wolf that's more of a man
blythe the half-wolf is undoubtedly a
fan favorite amongst the elden ring
community for both wholesome and not
quite so wholesome reasons
but as pretty much everyone knows by now
his story does not end well for himself
or quite frankly for you because you end
up having to put him down but lots of
fans are left wondering what caused this
downfall of the prior good boy's
character was he conscious when this
happened did he knowingly decide to try
and end your existence buckle up and get
the tissues out because in this video
i'm going to explain the story and end
of blythe the half-wolf and it might
just break your heart you've been warned
to explain what happened with blythe we
have to start by explaining who he is
and to do that we have to explain what
he is blithe is the shadow of ronnie the
witch but not like you know a shadow in
real life and not like the shadow from
peter pan either in eldon ring a shadow
is an individual or entity that protects
the person it is assigned to and follows
them everywhere you know like a shadow
you can even summon up shadows to defend
yourself with a few different methods in
game such as the white shadows lore ash
of war or the alluring pot although
these are just temporary shadows and
they don't stick around for very long
however every imperian which ronnie the
witch is gets a living permanent shadow
assigned to them and no i'm not going to
go into what makes it imperial and
empirian because of its debatable nature
but if you'd like my full thoughts on it
i believe i go the most in depth with
that subject at the beginning of my
ronnie video actually so feel free to
check that out but anyway each imperian
is chosen by their own two fingers in
order to serve an outer god and to
ensure that the imperian is alive and
well their two fingers will give them a
shadow to protect them queen merica who
obviously is an empirian had a shadow
named malekith who is referred to as her
half-brother although we don't know if
that implies that there's a shared blood
between them or if it's more of a
step-sibling situation since ronnie's
shadow blythe is not her blood brother
according to iji he was accepted and
adopted by ranala rani's mother and was
raised with ronnie and is referred to as
ronnie's step-brother they even enjoyed
playing together like proper siblings
one other detail about shadows in the
game that's also unclear is whether they
are living beings or are just
fabrications of two fingers according to
the armor of vargrum the raging wolf
wolves are shadows of imperians this
makes sense since malekith is a dude
like wolf and blythe as a wolf-like dude
but also according to the armor vargram
aspired to be a shadow himself which
apparently is why he wore the white wolf
pelt on his helmet also this is a super
side note but there are so many cool
little details in the game it's hard to
separate all of them as you can see
vargram fights with what looks to be a
godslayer's greatsword in case you
didn't know that is the very sword from
which the godskin apostle's black flame
originates it was used by the leader of
the godskin apostles the gloam-eyed
queen who get this was also said to be
an imperial chosen by her own two
fingers if you want my theory on the
glow might queen and who she was check
out my melanoma video but i just thought
it was a really cool find to see this
regular man vargrum who aspired to be a
shadow of an imperian used the weapon of
an imperian the reason why i brought him
up though was that he was clearly an
actual human being who simply wanted to
be a wolf a shadow it's possible that
this means that this plus the fact that
malekith is called america's
half-brother means the status of being a
shadow is something that can be attained
by anybody but on the flip side the fact
that vargrim was still only aspiring to
be a shadow and wasn't actually a shadow
yet could also be proof of the fact that
you can never actually be one unless
you're born one i mean clearly shadows
are not 100 human and ronnie does say
pretty blatantly that blythe was created
by the fingers and shadows come with a
certain programming from the fingers
which i will get to in just a bit so i
personally am of the latter opinion that
shadows are created beings with no
physical mother or father anyway back to
blythe he was given to ronnie from the
fingers to protect her while she does
the will of the fingers emphasis on that
last part there thing is after not too
long ryan decided that she wanted
nothing to do with the fingers and
devised a plan to separate herself from
the destiny they wrote for her against
her will again for more info on her
story and her motivations feel free to
watch my ronnie explained video in a
nutshell though she decided that the
only way to rid herself of the influence
of the fingers would be to kill her
mortal flesh which is why she infamously
stole the rune of death and cast away
her physical body while sealing her
spirit to the doll that you see in the
game now remember what i said about
shadows coming with certain programming
see blyth was able to grow up with
ronnie as if he was her actual brother
and in doing so he grew to love her more
than anything and we know he loved her
out of actual love and not some sort of
pre-programming not only because of the
fact that he was raised with her but
also because when she decided to delve
into cold magic which is considered
heresy and anti the will of the fingers
by the way he started wearing a cloak
because even though the cold bothered
him anyway which may or may not be a
frozen reference he refused to leave her
side but the programming of a shadow
lies dormant until absolutely necessary
and it kicks in only if the shadow's
master the imperian defies the will of
the fingers eg tells us that if this
happens the empyrean's shadow will go
mad and instead try to kill the imperian
thing is when ronnie defied the golden
order and shed her mortal flesh long ago
blythe's love for his sister was so
strong that he was able to completely
defy his own programming as a shadow and
remain loyal at least for the time being
fast forward an unknown amount of time
and this is when you the player come
into the picture when you first meet
blythe which is up to how you progress
in the game you come into contact with
him first deep underground where he is
attempting to enter the eternal city of
nocron and receive a certain relic
essential to lady ronnie's mission but
he admits that he's a bit stumped and is
unsure of how to progress he was also
stumped as to why 9 out of 10 regular
viewers of mine are actually not
subscribed to the channel ok he might
not have said that but i definitely am
to the 90 of you watching please
consider subscribing help us grow the
channel increase the reach do lots of
good stuff and you can always subscribe
later anyway after talking to him then
talking to celevis the creepy puppet
slave dude then talking to selen you
eventually learned that in order for
blythe or yourself to enter nochron you
must first defeat the person holding the
stars in place ronnie's half-brother the
powerful general radon who has long
since gone completely bonkers blythe
considers this part of his mission in
service to his sister and goes with you
to fight against radon and is even
summonable in the fight once you best
this giant monster of a man the stars do
indeed resume their course and blythe
who i think canonically took part in
this battle stands there afterwards and
comments on just how awesome it was to
witness not only the fight itself but
the power that the living legend radon
must have had to hold the stars
themselves in place he then confirms
that one of the stars was actually a
meteor that crashed down into the lands
between opening up a new hole in the
ground that just so happens to lead to
you guessed it the eternal city of
nochron he is inspired you're inspired
so the both of you agree to meet down
there where you will once again fight
for lady ronnie and retrieve her
necessary relic you eventually make your
way downtown but for some reason you
can't find blythe which is funny since
he said he was headed straight here and
that he would wait for you so the
question is where is he if you return
and speak to egy he'll tell you that
blythe had returned to carry a manor and
told eg about the fight and everything
but that you shouldn't wait for him
because he was apparently given some
other important task directly from lady
ronnie and is no longer able to help out
with the whole nocron thing this however
is a lie because if you find the relic
in return to ronnie she acts surprised
that you were the one who found it and
not blythe meaning she never gave blythe
any different objective and was still
expecting him to return what actually
happened was eg tricked blythe into
becoming trapped within the forlorn
hound ever jail you can go there and
actually talk to blythe who is in fact
trapped within he states that eg trapped
him there and told him he would bring
only bail to lady ronnie which is an old
english word that means evil or physical
torment blythe is confused by this and
claims that there's no way that could
happen because he is a part of ronnie's
very being her shadow her brother you
have the option to free him at this
point but spoiler alert it doesn't
matter if you do or don't because he
finds a way to break out either way if
you do free him though you can then get
a bit of extra dialogue where he says
again that he has no idea what came over
eg but now needs to return to ronnie's
side to make sure she's safe he's not
used to being away from her for this
long after all at this point if you talk
to blythe you can then return to egy and
confront him about what he did to blithe
this is when eiji explains to you that
shadows are pre-programmed to turn
against their masters if their masters
turn against the fingers which ronnie
already did long ago he says that no
matter what blithe believes or thinks he
will eventually become a horrid curse
upon lady ronnie such is his destiny and
interestingly enough if you talk to him
after blythe breaks out without you
freeing blythe eg will then say that he
made a grave misjudgment and this is
interesting because we're left wondering
what exactly eg is referring to that's
supposed to be a grave judgment this is
a personal headcanon of mine but i
believe he's referring to the fact that
he explained blithe's baleful destiny to
him before locking him in the ever jail
and now blythe is free i think eg knows
that blythe would have been okay if he
didn't explain this to him telling bly
that he'll bring nothing but bail to
ronnie probably sparked that programming
in blyth's mind and is now the reason
why blythe is wrestling with this inside
himself at this point blythe can't be
found anywhere and you have no choice
but to further ronnie's quest in his
stead along the way you're tasked with
defeating the last of the baleful
shadows which as i mentioned earlier are
shadows sent to ronnie by the fingers
for the purpose of killing her as per
their programming and wouldn't you know
it this last baleful shadow looks
exactly like blithe implying it might
just be a copy of blythe that didn't
grow up with ronnie and therefore didn't
overwrite its own programming in order
to defy the fingers like blythe did this
baleful shadow eerily foreshadows the
destiny of blythe the half-wolf and
indeed after you finish ronnie's quest
and receive the darkmoon greatsword
blythe can once again be found he's at
ronnie's tower where he was probably
looking for his sister he can be found
crouching over a black knife assassin
that he apparently killed and can be
heard under intense stress wrestling
with the baleful takeover happening
within his mind that was sparked from
eg's words and uttering his last sane
words no i'm part of her very being i
could never betray her no matter what
might happen ronnie she needs me and
then he succumbs to his baleful destiny
that he was always meant to become and
then tragically you have to put him down
just like that copy baleful assassin
before him blythe's story was one of
love and insurmountable loyalty that was
plagued with inevitable corruption
because of the will of the fingers and
at the end of his life he was left
confused and heartbroken that he ended
up becoming an assassin and bailed to
the very person he loved most in this
world a betrayal to her and to himself
but at least his cloak kept him warm all
the way until the end and that is the
story of blythe the half-wolf and his
tragic downfall but anyway what did you
guys think is blythe your favorite
character from eldon ring if not who is
and who do you want to hear about next
let me know in the comments below that's
all i've got for this one so you'll have
to excuse me i'm gonna go cry it out now
i hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day after you cried out this is bandit
looking forward to seeing you next time
and signing out
[Music]
you